first of all I would to thank
everyone for coming for com I us to this
the best group ever so everyone
especially the kids I would to
thank
you not that much but that much for
coming to Sunday school and for the
summer
school
say i' would to thank first the
students for coming I would also to
thank the parents for putting the effort
how are
you are you doing good are you going to
be a good missioner okay so I would like
to thank everyone I would to thank
the parents for putting the efforts and
bringing the kids for every Sunday
school I would also to thank them
for bringing them them for summer
school I would also to thank the
teachers
and I would to thank
first without your help and effort
Sunday
school it wouldn't
happen I would like
also I'm not going to to continue unless
you are listening to me I know it's not
fair for me when I talk and you do not
listen to me do you think it's fair for
me no it's not Fair
okay so I would also to thank the
teachers I would to thank teacher
can I see them sister have your
name for everything I would to
thank her I would to thank her also
relative she she left to
Palestine I would also
I don't want to forget anybody but I
would to thank also
teacher she's my mom so mama I would
Al also to thank
sister
Lum and first
name I really appreciate all your help
I will
I would also to thank
Dr Hussein and his wife for you know
also Hing for the summer school
especially
so everyone I know that I'm thanking
more you know a lot but you know
this is the minimum that I can tell
those
teachers and may Allah you know like
reward you and give you what you want in
and
give you what you want
in in we will have the we will continue
school we will update you through emails
insh the same way that we were
contacting on and communicating with you
insh T if there is any changes or
Improvement we would you can in
share it with the sheh or with me if we
did anything if we missed anything if we
were yeah missing anything forgive us we
are not perfect we are we tried our best
nothing will be perfect but
alhamdulillah I think from what you see
masallah we have a big number
alhamdulillah the students were
improving alhamdulillah it's only once a
week so forgive us for any for any
thing that we did not if we did not meet
your expectation forgive us and in we
will improve in the
futureal
the only thing you know I just
want to say that I wasn't here for this
summer because I was busy so if I'm
missing anything just forgive me because
I'm not updated with few few information
so sorry for
that so if there's anything please let
us know we are here to in help you and
help your kids and the only thing
that I want to say Sunday school is not
enough once a week to teach Quran
Islamic Studies and Arabic it's not
enough for our yeah for our kids so
hopefully in we will have a better way
to educate our students and we will have
you know enough time for those for
our kids inshal so forgive us again and
in if there's anything you are more
than welcome to share it with
us
and especially this group I love this
group The M the oldest I'm very happy I
would to share one story from him I
asked him why you are coming to this
Sunday school and he said because really
I'm learning right so alhamdulillah and
this is from his mouth alhamdulillah
this is something I think it's good so
alhamdulillah the the only reason for
them and he's putting the effort and I
heard that he's mallah especially
brother Muhammad he's coming mallah for
even this is you know I think this
is small change is what we are looking
for if in we will have more in to for
you know to fill this m in for
especially I think we will have a better
generation
Muslims we
be next time we work together harder and
harder again
and forgive us